the united nations says china's
detention of uyghurs and other muslim
groups in the northwest and xinjiang
region may constitute crimes against
humanity
in a long delayed report the un's human
rights office said there was credible
evidence of torture forced medical
treatment and sexual violence in camps
which beijing calls training centers
the report urged china to release all
detainees and explain the whereabouts of
the disappeared
the chinese government opposed the
release of the report and rejected the
accusations as a western-backed farce
human rights groups have welcomed the
findings as a powerful rebuttal to
beijing's long-standing denials of abuse
this report should be a wake-up call to
the international community as to the
reality of what is happening in xinjiang
there is now ample evidence that the
chinese government is committing grave
human rights abuses in xinjiang
including crimes under international law
correspondent fabian kretschmer joins us
from beijing fabian this isn't the first
report of its kind
what's different about this one though
well many of the facts were already well
documented before but the un report
gives it a whole new level of
authenticity and also urgency um
yeah so i would say that um the report
is very strong because it's not only
based on the
witness of human rights victims but it's
also based largely on official data
government data and that puts the
chinese government in a really uh weak
spot because they always deny any
wrongdoing
but
and don't even agree on the facts but if
most of the information is provided by
the government itself uh that doesn't
really make a lot of sense so really the
the pressure against uh against beijing
is really increasing we mentioned their
potential crimes against humanity can
you expand on that
yeah sure so um the report says that um
there are really grave human rights
violations and possibly even crimes
against humanity that is basically one
of the most severe possible accusations
um the report specifically mentions
forced labor in those
political re-education camps and it also
mentions torture physical torture and it
refers also to the very drastically
plunging birth rates in some of the
counties in xinjiang and
experts and researchers have attributed
that to four sterilizations however what
the um report did not do it did not
answer the question whether what
happened in xinjiang constitutes a
genocide or cultural genocide or not it
doesn't really mention that question
based on the fact
of what you mentioned about
this evidence from
official documentation
what would you say about
the
reaction of beijing's
yeah so in the first reaction basically
beijing denied um everything it doesn't
really um deal with the criticism it
only says that this u.n report is uh is
stunned by a western governments and
what will happen probably is um that the
government here will
ramp up
censorship i don't think that the
criticism will find its way into the
chinese public discourse and also
probably xi jinping the state leader
will um
ramp up the nationalism here because in
six weeks there's a historic party
congress during which he will most
likely proclaim a third term in office
and during that time um yeah
stability is key for the leadership here
and they don't want to deal with any
criticism or
anything that could cause instability in
their eyes so i think the nationalism
will only get worse in the coming weeks
and um probably let me just briefly add
that sure and they will establish the
ratif that um
yeah they will establish the narrative
that basically the west is trying to um
limit china's rise and they will
basically victimize themselves and don't
want to deal with any criticism okay
fabian krejcimer in beijing thank you
very much for the insight
you